foreign
let's go out to Alex in Sellersburg
Indiana what's up Alex
Hey Brother John how are you partying
man what are you up to
oh I'm just hanging out making horse
noises and buzzing or uh blaring some
Little Drummer Boy and having a good
time
well you obviously have a much better
producer running your life than I have
running mine because I have had all
those things taken away from me so good
for you Alex
Kelly likes my wife took away Drummer
Boy which thank God she did because I
hate that song and Kelly took away my
horse noises so I'm glad you're in a
better position Alex thanks for kicking
me while I'm down so what's up
hey to be honest I I'm not a giant fan a
little drummer boy
you know who is nobody and serial
killers that's who all right so what's
up
so I guess the the short answer or
question is uh uh how do I be a better
dad
um it was a couple of weeks ago laying
in bed like I said just hanging out and
uh wife rolls in and says hey who's got
two thumbs in this pregnant and Uh I
that said well not me and so uh that's
how she told you
pretty much yeah and then yeah
hey well good morning Alex and uh that's
incredible get some coffee that is
incredible hey at least you didn't go
get whiskey you went and got coffee
you're already off to a good start man
um she said don't freak out and and so I
did and here I am I'm calling you
I didn't know where to turn so I called
the podcast guy
um man so you you haven't had an
opportunity to be a bad dad yet so what
do you what are you stressing about what
are you worried about
or what about this whole this whole
thing freaks you out
actually number two okay uh baby number
two
um and he's
okay
um and I guess uh every and so are we
all the cried out method think about
that
um I I've heard that's that's bad don't
do that but I've also never been told
okay well don't you know throw the doors
open guns are blazing at every time you
hear him whimper
um so I'm and things like that just uh
you know uh spend time with them well
how much time I try to spend as much as
I can and then uh you know and then when
in discipline uh he's in this uh our
baby number one is in this throwing
phase and you know he just the other day
through something and and broke uh uh a
glass something earlier I can't I think
it was a candle or something and I I uh
okay well don't spank them don't but
they tell them no and so I sit here and
and wrestle with all these uh all these
aspects whether it be the crowd out or
the the discipline or spending time and
I feel like it's like I'm swinging far
one way as in
um you know every time I hear him cry or
you know just a little bit in bed I want
to come running in or I swing back far
the other way where okay well let's give
it let's say 10 minutes 15 minutes yeah
and and like I don't
um I don't have a good I guess uh
straight line path to follow as if there
is one
um so you know I guess I'm looking for
any advice still even as a dad of a
two-year-old and a soon infant I just
feel like I'm like I said I'm all over
the place yeah
um
I don't know if this is this will mean
anything to you but
um
you're in a very common place for dads
of two-year-olds
like there just comes this moment when
you're like what am I doing you know
what I mean like yeah I I like you said
I I want this I want there to be
a set of Ikea instructions I don't care
how complicated it is I'll figure it out
and I just need to put this thing
together
and then somebody sends you a podcast
that says well don't do this and then
somebody gives you a book that says
don't do that and then you just snap in
the moment and default to something that
your dad did that you had promised you
weren't gonna do right and it's just
it's a failure Factory and by the way
two-year-olds are two-year-olds and so
they can be the best at snuggling up and
they can rip your heart out
right oh yeah
and it doesn't also help that your wife
probably looks like she knows exactly
what she's doing
works with a lot more kids than I do
and so you just end up and so I I'll
walk through it with you and then I'll
Circle back here's where
many many many men including myself find
himself
baby number one
about this time
and you just start feeling like I am
more in the way that I'm helping
anything
and every time I try a thing my wife's
like God why just do it like this
because she's been babysitting since she
was six and nobody would trust me with
their kid when I was in Middle School or
high school and or fill in the blank
there's just every little thing
and so when I started I'll just speak
about me I started leaning a little bit
more towards you know the one thing I'm
good at is my job I'm good at that I
could at least go do that I'll make
money for the family
and so I just kind of turned the wheel
two degrees
and I ended up way far away from my
family so you're in a moment kind of
like a boxer is when he keeps getting
tagged from the outside
the Temptation is to back up a little
bit further away
when the best strategy is to bite down
on your mouthpiece and lean in and get
closer
okay so let me tell you this you're not
gonna quote unquote figure this out
because as soon as you figure it out
your second kid is going to be so
radically different than from your first
one you are gonna you're gonna feel like
you got half the Ikea thing built and
then they shipped you another set of
instructions that's completely that says
something totally different
and so the best thing you can quote
unquote figure out
is you
who am I gonna be when I get frustrated
am I gonna let a two-year-old or a
five-year-old or a 16 year old dictate
my emotional regulation
when I find myself getting overwhelmed
and frustrated which happens to all of
us it still happens to me regularly and
I do this for a living
what am I gonna do am I gonna yell am I
gonna throw a temper tantrum am I going
to tell my wife hey I need to take 10
and go outside
um am I just going to grab a trash so I
can start emptying the trash in a huff
like some dads do like what do you what
who are you gonna be
all right right yeah and my dad was the
the Yeller and the slamming of the door
right and the dad and I'm certainly not
bad but I find myself saying like like
it go back to the thing he threw and
broke the candle or whatever like I I
was sitting here thinking what do I do
and I just get sick yeah I get so tied
up and thinking about what to do how to
respond to where it's like I did nothing
and the next time he does it you know
then you I start thinking oh God this is
just a behavior and this is how that
screwed him up he's just gonna be this
defiant little baby and uh well I had my
chance I blew it or you know on the
laying in bed crying oh that was five
minutes too long
I've screwed them up and and he's gonna
have emotional problems for the rest of
his life and you know so like I said it
just kind of freeze and and what to do
and I
I I don't know
so I guess think think this way what I'm
going to say is gonna sound so cheesy
okay but here's what I want you to lean
into
I like cheese I do too man I love it I
love it
um
respond in love
here's what that means
when my baby cries now when they're
older I've got you know my kids are
older I can and you'll be able to tell
in short order like this is a real cry
this is not a cry this is a fussy cry
this is unfrustrated cry this is I need
somebody or I'm scared cry
there's times when the most loving thing
you can do is to hold your two-year-old
accountable in an appropriate an
age-appropriate two-year-old way
right he's not going to want to be a kid
who's throwing and breaking things
he feels wild and out of control he
doesn't like that it's discomforting he
needs a parent to set boundaries he
doesn't need a parent to come and swing
it at him
he doesn't depend coming in to scare him
to death by screaming at him
but he does need to learn hey if you
choose this then you also choose this
whatever that consequence happens to be
Okay so it's but all of that you see how
calm I am because I'm not giving a
two-year-old my I if I leave stuff on
the ground that a two-year-old can
destroy and it's going to be devastating
to me that's my fault because I'm the
adult
so I've gotta change how my house looks
and I gotta move stuff so that he can't
have things that he can break and
two-year-olds will figure it out
I saw my daughter climbing up the
cabinets the other like a spider and I
was like I don't even know what to say
to you right now I don't I don't have
any what are you doing literally what
are you doing
um she's trying to get a knife off I
mean it was just like what okay right so
the most important thing in that moment
is all right was it been four minutes or
six minutes no no no no
that's not gonna mess your kid up
and I I even hesitate to say this out
loud if you're thinking about
quote-unquote messing your kid up it's a
parent that is immobilize himself with
anxiety with tension because they don't
know how to respond in love see what I'm
saying
okay yeah and so I want you to spend the
bulk of your time
if you feel like you need to get up and
go hug your kid and it's been 30 seconds
instead of the agreed upon four minutes
get up and go hug your kid because you
know
okay
you're not gonna mess your kid up and if
your kid cries it out for a few minutes
longer than you you're not gonna mess
your kid up
and you there will come a moment if you
come from a yelling house when you snap
it'll happen
you're not gonna mess your kid up
especially if you take a knee and you
look them in the eye and you say I'm
sorry you get done on their level and
say I absolutely blew that and I as your
dad I'm sorry
see what I mean because you're gonna
mess up a lot and they're gonna go to
see a counselor someday and be like and
then my dad did this and you're gonna be
like yeah I did that
right who are two or three men just name
them their first names
that have a kid who's seven or 10 or 14.
that you can regularly call and or go
get coffee with go grab a drink with or
whatever
uh
exactly that's your yeah that's your
mission
okay
uh no one but I don't want his advice
but
I got those friends too who I love and
if it's wartime I'm calling them dad
advice not so much I'm good I'm good
yeah exactly yeah yeah I want you to
instead of trying to find another blog
to read about I want you to get two or
three men that you absolutely trust and
you see there the fruit beared out in
their kids
okay and I've got several people in my
life who raise their kids very very
differently one's homeschooled one's
public schooled one is very very very
very wealthy one is not wealthy at all
one is right in the middle
but their kids are funny
and I like being around their kids
and their kids are super respectful and
kind and their kids work hard and some
of their kids get D's and C's but
they're busting their butt and some of
their kids get straight A's and they're
busting like you see what I'm saying
like I want to ask those men those women
hey how what's the next right move here
that's where I'm gonna Garner a lot of
my wisdom okay but you see what I'm
saying you're spending the majority of
your energy
on who am I gonna be when my kid fills
in the blank like does whatever
right yeah yeah I think I'd do a good
job of being like firm
um as in uh like well actually just
yesterday yesterday evening
um he likes suckers so if we sit down
and you know watch TV for a second he
can have a sucker but he got up and kept
running and so no surfing I'm running
with a sucker in your mouth when you're
two so you know bug lost a sucker man
they can't hold still and I felt
horrible about it but I also you know I
had this vision of a two-year-old
falling with a sucker yeah that's cool
that's called keeping your kid from
dying it's one of that's that's yeah
that's dad 101 right or yeah and stuff
like that and then I think we'll shoot
was there something maybe something else
I could have done no no no no the kind
of stuff I get I mean I just go down
those rabbit holes and and things like
that and like oh well we watched YouTube
video of trackers he loves tractors and
I say oh he's seen a phone and a
smartphone and no we know what
smartphones do and you know that those
are the kinds of things that I run down
and I guess I just get caught up in the
paralysis of the analysis yeah and sit
down I mean I've got all kinds of books
of half-read you don't need any more
data brother you need some relationships
all right
you know how to be a good dad don't let
your two-year-old run with a sucker in
his mouth
sure yeah you know what I mean and I
want you to
consciously practice now
practice right now when you take that
sucker away and he gets those big tears
in his eyes or he lays on the floor and
kicks and screams and you ignore him
and you feel awful feel that fully don't
run from that
because that is what Dad feels like
and when your two-year-old Wells up and
cries because you took away something to
keep him safe
or you took away something because he
made a choice and there was some as
consequences on the back end of that
that turns into when your kid is seven
and you say Hey you give me a hug before
school and he goes no dad I don't like
hugging you
dude that hurts right
or when they're 17 and they sit down and
they say Dad I fill in the blank with
whatever a life-altering decision they
made
right so start right now feeling oh
sometimes dad feels uncomping a dad
feels uncomfortable I gotta do hard
stuff I gotta tell my kid no and I hate
telling my kid no I gotta tell my kid
you made a choice and here's the here's
the consequence to that choice
right and for everybody listening don't
think I'm um like I do have I I very
much have a a research oriented like
response to cried out method and I've
got very much research oriented
responses to spanking and all I've got
opinions on all those things
and if we want to go down those rabbit
holes I'm happy to do that but
Alex is like most of us we have an
analysis of paralysis I like the way he
said that we over analyze everything and
we keep seeking more data more data more
data more data more data more data
instead of more relationships
and if you just text somebody while
you're sitting there if you've got three
or four guys that you trust three or
four women that you trust and you can
just text them and say hey
my kid is a rashed it looks like this
and they'll all respond all cool simple
no problem
whew that's gonna go to the ER hey guys
my two-year-old just ran with a took off
running with a lollipop in his mouth and
I took it out and he just started crying
really hard am I a terrible Dad no
you're a great dad all right cool we're
just practicing we're just learning new
stuff
so focus on the relationship Parts
you'll get the other things right you'll
get some of them wrong and that's all
right and that's why you want friends
that can push back on you
um and man I'm happy to work through
individual situations if you call
but the bigger picture is the tension
and the anxiety I'm I'm I'm usually
outside of abusive situations I'm more
worried about that with the kids than I
am whether it was two minutes or seven
minutes or five minutes or I swatted his
hand or I I'm way more worried about
does your kid feel electrified in your
presence or do you feel warm and safe to
your kid let's focus on that which means
we're not fixing the kid
we're fixing us
and that's a way harder proposition